i made a marshmallow ron swanson oh
my gosh his arms are crossed because
he's mad at all the other marshmallow
workers for annoying him
you like it
it's fine
all my life i have avoided europe and
its multitudes of terribleness but it
turns out much to my surprise there is
actually one place in europe that is
worth seeing
[Music]
these tiny islands off the coast of
scotland where god's chosen elixirs are
distilled barreled and prepared for
consumption
this
is worth the trip
dear ron
you have now reached the cliffsides
overlooking the islands
as you sit here and gaze upon the waters
please read out loud the poem by the
great scotsman robert burns love leslie
a worm i love yon lilac fair with purple
blossoms to the spring
and i a bird to shelter there
when wearied on my little wing
how i would mourn when it was torn
by autumn wild and winter rude but i
would sing on wanton wing
when youthful may it's bloom renewed
[Music]
i don't know what she thought i'd get
out of that
[Music]
i have cried twice in my life
once when i was seven and i was hit by a
school bus
and then again when i heard that little
sebastian had passed
his memory
will live on
as today we light a fire
that will burn on for eternity oh my god
hey i found some towels
you okay
wow apparently craig is studying yoga
these are the only dry clothes i could
find well you look great i feel
extremely angry oh come on stop whining
you big baby i've seen you with your
eyebrows blown off i've seen you without
a mustache i've seen it all there's
nowhere to run ron you have tried every
possible means of escape there's nothing
to do but talk
what happened to these workplace
proximity associates
hmm
spill it
you left
then a month later you took terry with
you yeah well we needed a mindless fact
totem and he's the best there is hey man
then you took april
i didn't want her to go as she had
become one of my closest workplace
acquaintances
but your offer was too good to pass up
so i didn't try to stop her
and tom left to run his business donna
left to run hers
one day i looked up
just didn't recognize anyone
so i made a decision
an unthinkable decision
hey
well my my my do my eyes deceive me is
that ron swanson hello leslie
hello april larry uh it's terry now okay
as luck would have it oh did you talk to
randy about the vote tell the northeast
that we need to put pressure on them or
else we're gonna be waiting for everyone
i'm tired of waiting on them okay sorry
this is a crazy day so what's up with
you you big lug nothing important just
thought you might want to have lunch
uh tomorrow i would love to it's been
too long
jj's diner 12 30. excellent see you then
okay so randy says the house is voting
tomorrow and they need us in washington
to prep oh my god really okay get us the
first flight out of here and grab the
missouri files meet me at my car
hey babe i got to go to washington can
you pick up the kids
oh
oh no ron i stood you up for lunch you
did yes i waited for a while but it was
pretty easy to figure out what had
happened your life seemed pretty hectic
is that the rest of the story that i
stood you up
you were going to ask me something
that's why you wanted to have lunch
ron you were going i was going to ask
you for a job
in the federal government
just saying it out loud feels dirty
you missed your friends
and you wanted to come up to the third
floor and work with us again
i can't even imagine how hard that must
have been for you
god why didn't i see that
ron i am so sorry
i should have been a better friend to
you honestly leslie it's fine
it was a punctuation mark on a sentence
that had already been written my time in
government work was over i'm sure i love
shutting things down and bleeding the
rotting beast from the inside your
metaphors are so beautiful but it was
time for me to leave and i didn't feel
like explaining why to you or anyone
everything that happened after the fight
we had not given you a heads up when my
company took on the morningstar
development and
bulldozed the nurse's old house
i do regret that
i had a good run here
but after you and
tom and donna and april and terry left
when i looked around this office
nothing was the same
you